welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Flash season 9 The Final Season Barry
Allen The Flash has saved the world so
many times he and his wife Iris are
ready to live happily ever after in fact
thanks to all the time travel he knows
they're gonna live happily ever after
has their whole future mapped out in
this notebook which is kind of no way to
live so he and Iris agree to throw that
notebook away and let the future
surprise them the first surprise is
Caitlin snow working with Mark chill
Blaine trying to resurrect Frost who
died last season but we don't get Frost
or Caitlyn we get a totally new third
Persona with blue streaks in her hair
Keon luckily she's not evil she's super
nice got this innocence thing going on
because she's basically a newborn she
does have some icy powers but she's not
to metahuman or a cryo whatever Frost
was they run the science tests and turns
out she's literally the goddess of
nature Mark is hoping he and Keon can
pick up or he and frost left off he
takes her on a date doing Frost's
favorite things but she's like yo I'm a
totally different person now this isn't
me I'd love to go out for a walk in the
park but Mark's like oh that sounds kind
of lame the rest of Team flash these
days is Allegra Garcia with ultraviolet
light powers and Chester P rank the new
Science Guy they've had will they will
they office romance going since they
were introduced and now finally this
season they do and of course there's
former district attorney Cecile Horton
with her psychic powers who's become the
team mom this season she and Papa Joe
West realize that Central City is maybe
too dangerous a place to raise a kid
Papa Joe's retired he wants to move out
to the country but Cecile has her law
practice here plus she's one of the only
superheroes team flash has left they
finally compromise and buy a house
outside the city that Cecile visits on
weekends as always Central City is
attacked by new metahumans but these are
new old amount of humans like a new
Captain Boomerang and a new Fiddler
they've all teamed up so to fight them
flash recruits his own team of reformed
Rogues turns out their boss is a new
Speedster wearing a red bat suit indeed
it is an evil alternate timeline
Batwoman whose goal is to make like
psychic clones of herself and stop a
crime before it can happen and she's
working with Gorilla Grodd yes he's back
last time we saw him very convince him
to be a good guy but he's like no I'm
gonna be a villain again so Barry gives
him an even more passionate emotional
heart to heart that convinces him to be
a good guy again as for the Red Death
she's taken down by her doppelganger our
timelines good Batwoman who gets the
resolution to her show here the next
villain up is Ramsay Rosso blood work
who has been escaping from prison for
three seasons now this time he possesses
Wally West who kills Barry Allen but
here in the afterlife berries met by
Oliver Queen the Green Arrow yeah he's
back remember he's the Specter now
guardian of the Multiverse and because
blood Works threatening the Multiverse
he's able to come on back for one last
ride now there's a nine month time Jump
as iris is pregnant with their baby Nora
but wait what's this very zoinked out of
there teleported to the Past in fact
it's the day his mom is killed turns out
Barry was brought here by this
mysterious blue crystal that is the
negative speed force yeah it's floating
through time possession Barry's friends
just to mess with him Barry's Arch Enemy
the reverse flash eobard Thon has
traveled here today for his master plan
to kill kid Barry and so this is it it
is our current Barry who's the one
fighting Dawn on this night of his mom's
death he tells a season oneself not to
interfere closing that Loop then runs
his kid's self to safety letting Thon
kill his mom and as we know Thon lost
his speed ended up trapped here to go on
and incite the events of season one
meanwhile in the present the negative
speed force possesses chill blame but
Keon deals with him easily she can just
disintegrate him I guess and then bring
him back but the negative speed Force's
real master plan is 20 years in the
future where somehow we've got back
Eddie Thon yes from season one iris's
cop fiance who sacrificed himself so his
descendant Tia barthon would never be
born though somehow he kept coming back
anyway so I guess that ended up not
mattering as for Eddie he thinks he's a
scientist at Mercury Labs till one day
he's struck by lightning he starts
remembering his past life goes to dig up
his body and realizes somehow he's been
brought back and he goes to get help
from future team flash led by Barry and
irish's daughter Nora but now Nora finds
the mysterious blue crystal no one can
resist picking this thing up and know
she's possessed she shows Eddie what his
future could have been if he didn't die
I would be your daughter with blonde
hair so Eddie pays a visit to Future
Iris like look at the life we could have
had but it's awkward when your zombie
ex-fiance wants to get back together
Iris shuts him down and so Eddie Thon is
a real good guy but it's disorienting
being brought back to life in the future
and being haunted by the negative Force
so he decides to give in to those
negative emotions and Chase the life he
could have had becomes the negative
speed force Avatar he becomes the new
Speedster villain cobalt blue though his
lightning is red so he and Flash have
their Speedster fight and he gets the
upper hand but remember the flash isn't
alone he's got team flash to back him up
but Eddie's recruited some friends of
his own because somehow the negative
speed force can just bring people back
to life so back for the finale you are
the biggest Speedster villains from the
run of the show yes Zoom from season two
savitar from season three uh godspeed
tier 2 and of course the Harrison Wells
face version of eobard Thon the reverse
flash who just never stays dead so it's
the final showdown with the strongest
villains flash has ever faced yeah
running around well in the end all the
good guys win so Eddie's like I need to
be faster he's going to absorb all the
power of the negative speed force which
like Thon did last season would just
overload and kill it but Barry can't let
that happen to Eddie who is normally a
good guy plus if he dies the negative
speed force will just find a new Avatar
and the cycle will never end and so it's
the final showdown inside the negative
speed force and I'll give you three
guesses how Barry wins yes an emotional
heart dark talk that convinces Eddie to
be a good guy again he's going to take
one for the team and stay as the
negative speed force Avatar but just
choose not to be evil I guess so the
forces can all be in Balance so the day
is saved as Iris gives birth to her
daughter Nora and the future looks
bright at the baby shower Papa Joe West
proposes to Cecile I thought they were
married this whole time Keon has to say
goodbye her time in this Mortal body is
over she needs to ascend to be the
goddess of nature but her leaving this
body leaves it open I guess for Caitlyn
snow to come back oh right she's alive
again and now new father Barry Allen
wants to spend more time with his family
so Barry runs out and shoots three
lightning bolts at a couple randos
across the world who I guess are flash
alternates from the comics and now get
to be flashes too but Barry Allen will
still always be the Flash and as he has
one final run through Central City just
like old times that's how the flash
comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
Recaps of TV and movies
[Music]